oui nous resterons calmes comme toujours
et s'il ya un moyen il ya toujours un
moyen
nous verrons pour l'heure pas moyen
d'observer un accord entre l'union
européenne et le royaume uni des
négociations toujours dans l'impasse
entre deux parties qui semble se diriger
vers un odile concernant les bases de
leurs futures relations moins de quatre
semaines avant la date fatidique de la
sortie de lieux malgré une situation
préoccupante
londres reste inflexible sur ses
exigences il reste très peu de temps
nous sommes à un moment difficile des
négociations londres ne compte pas
accepter un accord qui ne respectent pas
les principes fondamentaux de la
souveraineté de son côté l'union
européenne s'inquiète les vingt-sept
souhaitent un accord mais pas à
n'importe quel prix comme l'a confirmé
le porte-parole de la chancelière
allemande angela merkel
après une semaine entière de discussions
les négociateurs des deux parties
michel barnier david frost ont
communiqué vendredi soir
ils reconnaissent encore de nombreuses
divergences après une semaine d'intenses
négociations à londres avec david frost
nous avons convenu aujourd'hui que les
conditions d'un accord n'étaient pas
réunies en raison de divergences
importantes sur l'égalité des chances la
gouvernance et la pêche
ce samedi si la présidente de la
commission européenne s'est entretenu
avec le premier ministre britannique en
vue de faire avancer les négociations
si l'opération venait à échouer les
règles de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce appliquerait entraînant un
retour des droits de douane une
situation que chacun veut éviter en
pleine crise sanitaire